all right joining us now with reaction
of the unashamed podcast this book is
just out today and I literally couldn't
put it down it's called America's soul
blowing the lid off the lies that are
destroying our country well he is the
patriarch of duck dynasty Bill Robertson
along with Jase and Al and you have no
beard which makes you the outcast
mustard know what that means but I
remember the monsters yeah
well I'm really worried about the
country were we two years on this
program uh I have an ensemble count to
take any credit for we all we've been
digging and digging this Russian
conspiracy like illusion attempt to take
down a president rigged an election
rigged an investigation of the opponent
spy on Americans is real there a real
clear present danger to our future in my
opinion your book captures it well I've
just tried to warn the country I love
I'm told you love God and love my
neighbor therefore that mean liberals
sorry just can't eat me because I don't
like you eat meat I'm not calm down yeah
that's wrong I'm not giving up my cows
for nope so we go through the food laws
and all this stuff but I love them even
if they don't sit down a listen the
scary part about the the liberal left
because they did not think it worth
while the Apostle Paul said to retain
the knowledge of God he gave them over
to a reprobate mind to do what ought not
to be done and the list is this long and
it ends up there God hater slanderers
and their senseless faithless heartless
ruthless I mean one of the big ten it's
a metal that's why I said that theft of
America's soul I meant the evil one this
is a true story
Jase you know this is true I'll you know
I met your place in West Monroe
Louisiana
I watched duck dynasty I remember the
alligators that were on your property
you live in a trailer with the with the
oh you rich man and you have a filthy
seat that you won't get rid of change
the seat this K has a mansion a kitchen
behind your your trailers it's
unbelievable to me
you wanted to take me in that alligator
pit
there a mo skinnier then and you want to
dunk me in the alligator swamp to
baptize me yes it'll earn to trust in
the Lord Jesus article out today about a
crocodile leading a pastor baptizing
people for your sake because you're a
little spooked about alligators you got
to remember something it's more you will
have more trouble with cottonmouths but
i feel most of the city in this bill and
somebody has one and we'll go down to
the jacuzzi where i know there's no coos
you can baptize me in a jacuzzi I
believe believe in Jesus the Son of God
came to cleanse us from our sins I
believe that now all you do now is get
rid of the old shown presence he said
yeah I was a sinful man I said so was i
well what you were bad by the way you
had a bet you're a battle what about you
what about a few kabuto said well are
you talking to me he said kabuto a good
one yeah he said it's getting hot in
here all right true story so you guys
are in trouble
I've learned a long time ago of a very
dear friend of mine you don't call your
friends when they're happy you call them
when they're in trouble you're getting a
controversy I remember I called you yeah
you're the only one Willy was in a tree
hunting
good grief and I answered you answer
whose it was 6:00 a.m. your time in West
Monroe Louisiana you guys are out duck
hunting this is all the conversation go
hey y'all hold it up is it okay and this
is like oh hang on a sec quack quack
quack and I'm finally I'd like he forgot
him on the phone here and give a rip
what I have to say you didn't care you
even want to talk to me remember they
call oh yeah what's because we've gone
public with our faith and when you do
that you're gonna be attacked that's the
bottom line that's why we're doing our
podcast now you don't say you're sinners
you say you're the widow center everyone
answer I'm more incorrigible than you
but go ahead
the
yeah we're all sinners the difference is
when we mess up we're honest about it
we're truthful and we use that as a way
to show people to overcome adversity and
trust in God and that's what we do but
what we're trying to do is change the
human heart you see in the political
world you know everybody's up in arms
because every time you know a school
shooting happens I mean it it pains us
and it hurts us or so we get into the
same debates about guns which we use
common sense because we all have guns we
don't want to do we know it's the human
heart is my point
surround schools with retired military
retired cops guess what that's the end
of school let me give you my idea right
here you train a couple of teachers if
you don't have them there we'll bring
them in there
don't tell anybody who it is just like
they do all the cleaners now are you and
we have been then you do the greatest
thing you teach about love that's a
required subject can't mention card and
a publisher look I'll quote the verse
love is kind love is patient it does not
in me it's not easily a good podcast I
threw it up on my workflow throw it up a
micro website Hannity calm Greek to
shield god bless you all thank you for
coming I can't you good to [ __ ] out sir
you need a beard man yes they are
getting more airtime of the businesses
in your neighborhood you saw